for that answer and more we bring in the
Patriots radio color analyst Scott Solak
the former Patriots quarterback what was
the reaction Scott when the Patriots
signed Cam Newton well I mean we we had
the greatest name to play the position
for 20 years and what he departs and
your left foot Brian Hoyer and Jared
stood and I liked both those guys I know
Brian really well he's been here
multiple times you know they go at
Stidham last year to be the only got a
backup backup Tom Brady so you lose the
name you lose the I'm gonna say ego I
think you lose that personality that
leadership in the locker room and then
BAM you hear Cam Newton's name after
hearing not a single thing for three
months three and a half months because a
co vid I mean we really haven't had any
sports to talk about it's just when our
team's coming back what's gonna be
protocol but man when Cam Newton's name
dropped a lot of people got excited
because Cam Newton really played well
against us at a couple games that he had
against okay is he gonna be the starter
this year if you were gonna gauge if you
have to ask me I'd say no given given
and I said it's not because he's a bad
plays AB and fantastic transcendent type
player I love watching him play I love
calling games against him this offense
here so predicated on timing in detail
and I think that's why you had the
frustration with the quarterback here
last year was because people weren't in
spots where you expect and expect him to
be he wants to throw the ball into holes
cam is a big play player and when I say
that he's seven steps he's off the back
foot he waits he waits a runaround sort
of like Ben he's very similar to Ben
Roethlisberger and he likes to push the
ball downfield
you know this whole offense here is it's
one two three yards out to Edelman and
get the ball into play makers hands and
I think the timing Dan may hurt him the
most because if you said okay we got cam
back in March and he had three months
under normal circumstances where you had
OTAs throwing camps being around all the
guys in the locker room it's a great
locker room they will embrace him for me
it looks like it's a two-month trial for
him and maybe it was bargain I don't
know that I didn't talk to anybody that
if he doesn't get the job I can't see
camps sitting there on the sidelines you
know week two in Seattle with a
clipboard baseball hat on backwards
that's just not who he is he should
starter how good is Stidham it's pretty
good it's pretty good I'm very cerebral
doesn't get rattled a lot cut a lot of
called a lot of preseason football games
for this team over the years especially
going back to Garoppolo and that's the
one thing I compared Stidham to know I
don't care I don't compare student the
Brady you don't compare anybody to bring
so I looked at what they gave Jimmy
preseason wise and a lot of it was basic
power i single tight and two wide
receivers for Jared last year they threw
the kitchen sink at him and threw it at
a pretty good meeting they went empty
two tight ends multiple sets three wide
four wide no backs and you know he
handled everything and directed
everything traffic wise with the hands
on the road in Detroit he throws the
heck out of the same ball like the what
like his delivery on the dig cuts and he
doesn't flinch when people hit him for
and that's funny because he got
shell-shocked with Auburn you know that
last year he was there yeah he's
athletic I think people you know they're
looking at can you run the same offense
for Cam that you do for Stidham and vice
versa do you think that's possible with
New England III think you I think New
England was stood him they would keep
probably 80% of their offense and it
tweak it to help him and see what he
does well that's really really good what
Billy O'Brien and Josh McDaniels have
done over the years they they really
help the quarterbacks flourish and what
they do well instead of taking that
square peg and fit it in a round hole
and everybody you know in our talk show
up here oh it's gonna be great to get
came here and you can put him in a
wildcat said you could run him there's a
reason cam got banged up and that's from
running around getting outside the
pocket you know he's so big I mean he's
listed at 6 6 240 I'm that he's 275 man
this kids a rock and defensive teams
were tee off on him if I'm bringing Cam
Newton in I want to keep him in a pocket
I want to protect him and I want to know
if he's open to being coached by Josh
McDaniels meaning it's hard to strip a
guy down mechanically after 9 10 years
where he does things a certain way if he
drops the ball but seat the ball in the
chest can you hit that fifth step and
get rid of it
if cam is open to that and he's gonna
have a pretty good shot and win a
starting job here yeah I just don't know
if you can change him Scott because the
reason why I bring in cam is I want him
to be cam it I can't say hey come on in
let's be a pocket passer it defeats the
purpose of bringing in Cam Newton he's
not good enough to be just a pocket
passer and that's why I go with the edge
stead of dama it's exactly the way I
think - yeah you said he's no Tebow
obviously Cam's a phenomenal player we
had Tebow in camp here for a while and
it was just frustrating watching them
try and work with him mechanically like
the short leg shorten the the spread of
the feet come more over the top and less
like a baseball player and he's thrown
on Aaron looks like he was thrown paint
cans out there you got Brady company a
boom that balls pop reset we see some
pretty good guys he's the Patriots
Raider radio color analyst former
Patriots quarterback Scott dholak what
happened first
Belichick decided he didn't want Rainey
back or Brady decided that he wanted to
go out in his own style having fun it
seems like if this was Tom's decision
based on what he think was Howard Stern
he told that right what Stern asked him
when did you know you were out of New
England and he said probably before
probably the summer before last year
there yeah so to put a timetable on it
there and that's really when he
negotiated to not have that franchise
tag so to me that's where he calls the
shots and hey Bill was fine with it - I
think Billa bills always the 20 years is
a long time in any business and any
marriage in any relationship you'll
never see that again I'm sure we'll
never see that again and it's gonna be
tough because they still have a good
football team here and expectations are
still very high but our schedules
extremely difficult the team hasn't been
practicing as much as we know you know
some guys are still working out shortens
preseason it's a weird year I just hope
we have football what would you say to
the Seattle Seahawk fans I saw Russell
Wilson working out with Antonio Brown he
of course had a cameo with the Patriots
what would you say in regards to Antonio
Brown in Seattle if this thing's right
up top you know dad you know he's the
he's the greatest receiver in the league
he's the best is that that
I mean callgames when he was again when
he was in Pittsburgh to watch him
separate to watch him use his body on
the law on ball just to accelerate
decelerate to create space the kick
return game
he's explosive and watch him here in
practice break guy's legs and just the
feet his feet are so quick it's a shame
it's a shame this guy hasn't played
football in two years because I think
when he's right he's the best in the
league it's good to see ya now that's
not a tampa color shirt that you have on
is and certainly not patriots there
scott my last day we tried to do this
show yesterday my last day was working
the real studio show let's say golf
shirt it's a greg norman old golf shirt
and i play like an old man I'm willing
to play golf after this right now but it
seems like that's an homage to Tom like
you're kind of sending a message to Tom
right now while not sending a message to
Tom right now it's my man Tom Brady
thank you Scott all right Dan take care
that's Scott so Lac